hello everyone welcome back to Scotland
and welcome back to the island or zabi
whiskey distillery Chester's tournament
its Magnus Carlsen versus his old rival
Sergei hurricane as you all know the two
of them have played the World Chess
Championship match in 2016 which
crossing one obviously he is still the
champion and it's really a crazy game
the whisky immortal if you will I'm sure
gonna enjoy it
so without further ado let's just check
it out and I just want to say I do
appreciate that you enjoyed the little
sip of whiskey but until i acquire at
least a better one I don't think I will
be making the other thing maybe next
year if they repeat this tournament I
will try to acquire a better one and
then maybe we can have some sips before
before checking out the games as the one
I have is really just well it's really
really disgusting so without further ado
let's check it out Carlson has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 as it was
already on the board with Knight to f6
Knight to f3 sorry about that
we have d5 and now cousin doesn't go for
c4 but rather g3 also sort of a Catalan
setup we have g6 Bishop to g2 Bishop to
g7 kirkin follows everything calls and
us so we have a nice little metrical
variation we have castles castles and
here at c3 by crossing in the cote
d'ivoire
a blitz section that we covered some a
few days ago Knight B to d2 was played
here by Maxime for Sheila Graf and he
defeated wayyy
with the dis line but here Carlsen goes
for a different one we have c3 Knight
bt7 with Bishop to f4 and not c5 I just
you know don't want any backwards pawn
if white allows it why not push it all
the way we have Knight to e5 and now
Queen to b6 putting pressure on the BT
upon also pressuring the center here and
Causton does the same we have Queen to
b3 offers the Queen trade and we have C
captures on d4 by Kerrigan
Queen captures on b6 with Knight
captures night capture Sun b6 and now
see captures on d4 and pretty much
an equalization has been reached once
before in 1994 between bosnian
grandmaster emma desire of each and
croatian grandmaster modern palates
although i don't think they were
grandmasters back then but for example
they agreed to a draw in this position
but cross and incur keen didn't come
here to make such quick draws so we had
knights the e4 by car cane and it's
interesting that this position now
nicely for is a new move by Kirk in this
position hasn't been reached for 25
years so like I said the last time was
played in 1994 with nice to e4 by
kurakin and now rook to see one cousin
adapts to the to the deviation and
continuous plane so grabbing hold of
this very nice open file rook to c7 will
always be an interesting idea
so with Knight back to d6 going back and
here comes Knight to c3 just developing
and here Bishop to e6 you have to be
careful if you play something like east
if you could easily hang your knight
here just Knight captures and g6 opens
up an attack against your knight
so Bishop to e6 sometimes you have to
develop this way even though the bishop
now blocks your pawn but it is only
temporarily with a four by Carson
grabbing more space on the Queen side
preparing a five so we have a five by
kurakin not allowing a5 and now just H
for grabbing even more space on the King
side preparing h5 perhaps in some lines
we have rook F to c8 and now comes b3
just defending the F or pawn also not
allowing this night in any squares we
have looked the c7 carrucan prepares to
double up on the C file and cross on
doesn't allow it with knife to b5
attacking the rook forces a trade of
rooks and now crossing grabs hold of the
open C file with rook captures rook
captures and now Knight captures on b5 a
captures on b5 and only not worked the
c8 so Carlsen with the BB pawns as usual
as you all know Crossin does not mind
and doubling his pawns he somehow always
turns it into a strength and here rook
to c5 of course not capturing you don't
gain anything by this but here of course
you want black the capturing black
captures you improve your pawn structure
here you push c6 create a passed pawn
well
be a very very nice position for white
so of course car cane isn't interested
he starts to bring his King into the
game we have King to f8 and now II four
by Carlson trying to bust open the
position here we have a four by kurakin
and here we have a a critical position
if you will it's a critical position
because Carlson has to decide what to do
here there are a lot of interesting
ideas for example Crossin could go for
route captures in c8 and this pretty
much trades everything and we go into
this draw shangai master Bishop captures
on c8 b captures on a for nine captors
on a4 and now he captures on d5 grabs a
pawn but still it's a double to deep on
and after Knight c3 going after the b5
pawn be 694 you will recapture here your
black will have a past beep on you the
material on the board will be equal so
sort of an equalist position so that's
one way to do it for Qasim but he's not
interested in that he goes he captures
on d5 and I wasn't following the game I
was you know chilling outside yesterday
so but I did manage to catch this
position and the Twitter speed of the
chess 24 website where everything was
blinking a blunder a blunder so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
figure out why everyone was saying
blunder blunder I'll give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who are
interested in perhaps finding this
blunder for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent spotter of blunders if we will
call them that and for those who just
won't enjoy the show the move is a three
and this is what caution seems seem to
have missed the point is now after a
three we have D captures an e6 and now a
two you will not be able to prevent the
pond from Queeny
you have to go 90 d7 check and of course
you don't want to capture here because
then white also gets a queen but after
king jet you get night capture Sun b6
upon to a-1 with Queen this comes with
check King to h2 and now you can play
rook to d8 and here we have this
position where you have some pressure
and you have a queen for basically a
knight and the bishop so two pieces for
the Queen blacks position will be better
and blacks
position is to be preferred here but
kurakin didn't go for a 3 after
Carlson's eek after sandy 5 Crossin went
for a different line you played first
rope casters on c5 we have D captors on
c5 and only now a 3 but now it's a
little bit different first D captures
any six by Carson we have nine we have a
2 by car cane and now Knight to d7 check
and again we've said that this doesn't
work but we're just going to show why it
doesn't work if Knight captures lluvia
de captures and now a one queen with
check came to h2 and now Queen D for
preventing the pond from queening but
now White has a super blocking move
Bishop to d6 now just threatening have
fun to d8 and there's really no good
defense here whatever you do I would say
capture than just the d8 queen and
you've checkmated black so not an option
so here after this check a car a car can
win kinked sorry not a g8 king te 8 and
now we have Knight captures and b6 and
now car King gets a queen into the game
with check we have King to h2 and now if
you look at this position it's a bit of
a it's a bit of a different position
than the one that we've said that was
really really good for Kerrigan so here
we have this position where car can only
has a queen and the bishop against a
bishop pair and the night + White has
these two excellent connected pawns
whereas the position that we already
discussed was this where calls and
spawns are not connected across the card
and still has a rule the rooks haven't
been traded off and he has a lot more
options so this was a better line to
choose from
so after this King t8 like we said
Knight captures and B 6 a 1 with check
King h2 and now comes Bishop to e5 car
sorry Bishop to e5 car can offers a
trade of bishops with Bishop to e3 cross
and declines as now he has to he still
has to fight he's still hoping to create
a passed pawn here somehow push it all
the way to victory and here you can't
defend the b7 pawn just to give you an
example if Queen a7 defending c6 and now
after Bishop to c7 blocking and
attacking the knight you get C capture
son b7 Bishop Tadros on b6 but now
Bishop the c6 check and after the king
moves king f8 now you get bishop the
h6 check King moves and now Bishop to f4
will Queen the pawn and now wife will
just beat up a piece so not an option
here a car game played F captures on e6
and now we have Bishop captures on b7
khasinau eliminates the b7 pawn and now
he has to connected passed pawns which
is more than ready to push we have
Bishop back to d4 offering a trade now
you can't repeat because you'll lose the
f2 pawn so nice to see four here
crossing a defense and Kirk in hurricane
is able to grab the upper hand here with
Bishop captures on e3 Knight captures on
e3 and now Queen to be two by Kirk in
going after the f2 pawn but also an
interesting idea was Queen to a5 just
attacking the pawn here and only after
Bishop to c6 check King the eight now
you go Knights the c4 attacking the
Queen and after Queen to b4 you will
eliminate the c5 pawn there is no way to
defend it and Carson would be left with
two doubled pawns here on the B file but
after Knight captures only three we have
Queen to be two going after the f2 pawn
car crossing defense King g2 and now
comes Queen captures and b3 so this way
car cane eliminates the be three pawns
but Carson still has to connect passed
pawn so again different for the for the
second time in a row Kirk and misses a
crucial continuation to grab the the
much-needed advantage and here we have
b6 so a much better pawn structure for
Carson than the line we've shown where
where he could have ended up with a
double beep on we have Queen to b5 and
now comes Bishop to back to f3 Carson
still isn't interested sorry carbon
isn't interested in grabbing the c5 pawn
just yet but you know he he will get to
it we have King to the 8th now comes b7
the pawn is now nicely protected by the
bishop King to c7 and now comes c6
although Carson has his pawns protected
over here the King does an excellent job
by blocking both of them and the night
it doesn't really have a good way of
entering the position to help out with
the pushing of the pawns we have Queen
to b4 and now we have G
or Carlson pushes on the kingside we
have Queen to d4 and now comes Knight to
f1 cousin still trying to make it work
but you know just in case it doesn't
work it's important to create a fortress
so the White Queen will not be able to
break through which is or of course
always a challenge for constant as you
all know cross and does not believe in
fortresses with h5 and now comes G
captures on h5 I will G captures on h5
and now Knight back to g3 going after
the h5 pawn now we have E 5 by kurakin
now of course you cannot capture because
e 4 will be just very annoying Bishop e2
Queen can go to d5 now you will start
losing the pawns here as you cannot
protect both the bone and the knight on
on h5 the bishop cannot cover both tasks
so after E 5 with Knight to e4 just
blocking the pawn and now comes the
Queen to c4 again attacking the pawn
here but now Knight to g5 we have kinked
the b8 by kirkin and now Bishop to e4
blocking and quinta e 2 but just Bishop
to f5 cross and still trying to create
some chances if this night could somehow
miraculously get over to a6 to check the
king or perhaps the d7 to check the king
it would be great because then you could
Queen Queen the pawn with check but
Karpin will do everything in his power
to prevent that we have E for now you
have to be careful if you move the
knight and queen of e3 check could pick
up the bishop then you're lost
so Knight captures on e4 by Carlsen with
Queen to C for now
Knight goes back to g3 and now finally
grabbing the c6 pawn Queen captures on
c6 with Bishop to e4 as you're in check
you have to block with the bishop
otherwise you're losing the b7 pawn then
you're just lost
we have Bishop to e4 blocking and now
Queen to f6 and here Knight captures on
h5 attacking the Queen with Queen
captures on h4 and now comes Knight to
g3 and believe it or not it was in this
position unmoved
49 that caused an incursion agreed to a
draw as there is no no way for either of
them to make progress
there's even I mean it would be more
likely for whites to somehow man somehow
wind is then for black because well
could have to blunder if black plays
precisely then there's no way but
there's no way for black to make
progress you can't move the bishop the
knight is guarding it pong pong guards
the night king guards the pawn bishop
guards the b7 pawn there's no way to
make progress you cannot push the pawn
as even if you move the bishop back and
forth the knight and Bishop are still
controlling the e4 square so there is no
way to make progress here
you can't give any checks because the
bishop controls the only diagonal from
which the black Queen could deliver
check so it's just there's a draw and it
would seem Carlson has created a
fortress here so even though he he
doesn't believe in fortresses it would
seem that he only doesn't believe in
fortresses when someone is trying to
create a fortress against him when he
tries to create a fortress then it I it
would seem it's okay to create a
fortress but yeah here they agree to a
draw a very important role for Carlson
as this draw assured him first place in
this chess parcel endorse a be
tournament and I did prepare the stats
here here are the stats there is the
cross and with three and a half ding and
Karkand tied in second with three points
but ding with some better additional
criteria and Vishwanathan Anand in
fourth place with two and a half points
since he still didn't adjust in time for
the for the cold Scottish weather and he
played an excellent second day but in
the first day he he lost the game and
had two draws but crossing the only
player without without any any losses he
achieves his 55th win in a tournament
this year so already he won five
tournaments and I believe this is his
sixth tournament victory in a row so he
won six tournaments in a row that he has
played in next year he goes to Ultimo's
Norway championship which will start I
believe on 3rd of June and then they are
all coming Croatia in Zagreb to continue
the Grantchester so we will have some a
lot of chess going on you know for the
next month and a half into two months
basically but yeah and Holland is also
very much responsible for a course and
claiming first place here because if on
indeed haven't defeated King Lear and
and England would have won the
tournament
with with four points five points ahead
of magnus carlsen so even though anand
finished last year he helped carson to
hit the clinch first place and also as a
special bonus in this video I would I
would like to wish a happy birthday to
Michael here his fiancee sent me this
photo this is Michael as you can see
he's enjoying a nice beer and she asked
if I could transfer this message to
happy 2450 birthday to you Michael
I feel whew fulfil your passions and
keep on exploring the chest world will
always be mysterious and incredible with
love from your fiance Susan so there we
have it also wishing you a very happy
birthday hope you had a nice beer or you
know more of them and you know don't
forget to study the end game it's it's
the best part
yeah that being said I would like to
thank Pym the role of gbr and Knights
bar restaurant
Patricia King Simon Johansen and then is
the so Mia for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
still have to cover the finals of the
Fida grand prix and then we often till
the ulti box norway championship we will
be continuing the Capablanca saga and of
course checking up on your suggestions
so there you have it the whisky immortal
I do hope you enjoyed it like I said as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon have an excellent rest
of your day